oh we don't have seatbelts in this
corner I've never been on a farm there
was that farm I have been on a farm I
believe once and it was a cow farm but
I'm a vegetarian so I prefer the
vegetable farm by the time we got to the
farm they'd already been up for like
five hours got a lot for you to do today
you're gonna be walking through
cornfields and bean fields these corn
stalks can you see over them like is
there a way out it's just like a maze
you don't know where to go I don't know
what to do on a five we're gonna have to
learn the hard way
we're sampling the maturity of the
fields and that gives us a better idea
of what fields we should be harvesting
next go ahead and find the other orange
flag and grab 16 years porno I see a lot
of corn you got jokes gonna be funny I'm
hurting it oh no I think I just broke it
50:16 guy that was hot in there now
reduce some green bean sampling when you
get to our sample area take the dirt off
what I needs us to grab there's three
total feet at each location we were the
wrong pants wrong pants wrong shoes
everything wrong don't think I did that
right this is like three feet right
shake it shake it shake it up shake it
out there's a lot of not microwave it
involved I never knew that green beans
grew on plants yeah they grow on three
everything looks great I don't know how
you guys do this all day it's very
exhausting we're not done yet we're just
having lost and you believe would get
that in became within hours that's what
the dollar was hard work but the quality
was so good like I really appreciate the
word attention we did
I got a lot more cardio in than I
intended to today we got a surprise for
you you guys are gonna get to drive a
corn harvest harvest harvest it I used
to have toys and you know now I'm a big
kid that you know it's bigger than you
right oh my god I can't let it dominate
track I don't know what I'm doing my
childhood has come to life I'm only
going to whopping 250 miles an hour and
my sweet corn
let's see some sweet cars
[Music]
all right baby I can't open the door
when I'd love to go through the store
I'm gonna take an extra five minutes
just to stare at the cans cause we're
gonna do if they ever need somebody to
come drive a tractor I mean where your
girl your girl for sure you know we got
it in the bag so
[Music]